hi there reject nation I'm Greg
I'm John I'm 29 years old so is John huh
but we're gonna watch a video from ello
the mills super successful youtuber
burnt out at 19 and she's doing way
better than us 29 year old maybe we were
burnt out of 19 Huna oh man if I was
burnt out of 19 and had the success
she's had I'd be a happy burnt-out child
we rented a video from her forever ago
the most like him she married her
sister's boyfriend yeah this is a topper
watch a video request from new youtuber
Anissa Olivia she said just let you all
know when I first watched this video I
totally get where her mindset was but I
felt like that a lot that God as bad as
that at one point but I'm doing better
you'll see in the video at some points
though it's pretty hard to watch but
it's good to talk about and get it out
there more so expect a laugh a lot is
what I'm getting from this they're gonna
be triggered by this video from this bye
laughter yeah
I'm almost oh boy this is like eighth
grade Oh goddamn
Mars
[Music]
what is your dream job the police I want
to be when I was a kid all I ever wanted
to be was a youtuber I was actually
voted most likely to be a youtuber in
high school and after I graduated I made
a promise to myself that I was gonna do
it so I posted this what would you did
you t feel like one gene faceted
expecting a Canadian YouTube star l
Mills one break-up youtuber for the 10th
annual Shorty Awards you've definitely
had moments over the past year that have
brought in you new 1.2 million in the
fan of
[Music]
it's not Oh My Jesus
Oh
[Music]
over on her Twitter she released a video
which she is subsequently removed that
shorter visibly distressed and agitated
saying that although she's had all these
successes the pressure of social media
and the pressure of videos has
overwhelmed her to the point she was
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
your my favorite baby so do tell your
parents to and then there soon not only
is he one of the funniest people I know
but he's an incredible filmmaker you
really helped me feel inspired again now
let me introduce you the hazel
good hurry he's my mentor through which
is kind of ironic because emotions make
both of us uncomfortable she was able to
help me through her experiences and they
just meant a lot to me that she cared so
much and lastly there's duty I loved oh
do I
but I'll kill you if you tell her I said
that sure she's [ __ ] weird
but she's the most caring person you'll
ever meet she really took me under her
wing you made it a priority to help me
she even drive me to my first there's no
point I or a suitable one it won't give
you my videos usually have some sort of
unfortunately this
no I don't want to worry anyone I am
getting the help I need you had a bunch
of people looking after me and I will be
putting on the delivers for today if
anyone watching is also struggling with
their mental health I encourage you to
go talk to someone anybody because now
my sincere apologies if this ending is
not satisfactory for you but
unfortunately reality is it's an illness
video when I first started making videos
I need to make these little music videos
[Music]
[Music]
damn that's very video yeah that's a
great video that was real uh yeah I mean
this video I think is like a year or so
maybe like a year and a half old
actually
yeah May 1828 een so yeah about a year
and a half I don't follow
Elle Mills is like career trajectory I
didn't know she blew up in the span of
like six months is fine the day we're
filming this we covered an NF music
video or we talked a lot about how a lot
of times especially in Western culture
we associate achieving career goals as
happiness and now there's been a lot of
people you know you've heard your whole
life that money doesn't equal happiness
and that career success is not equal
personal life happiness but I still
think there's a thing in our brains it's
been ingrained that we still believe
that somehow it will equate to that and
most people don't reach the levels they
want to get that even like halfway in
terms of their career and these pursuits
the entertainment industry and whatnot
and we are nowhere near on the level of
Elle Hills other things that I could
definitely identify with them or when
this channel first started blowing up
and gain like a couple hundred thousand
subscribers and like a year at one point
there is this like weird pressure that
comes with it it's like you've never had
it before and now that you have it you
want to maintain it some people who may
not ever have been in that position
might be like I wish I had that problem
instead of the problems I have now but
really it's just a different kind of
problem and it's like with her videos
the way how she does them I'm always
impressed with the editing because she's
on camera and and it seems like she's
the one who does all the editing yeah it
seems like a third by her completely
yeah her editing is brilliant and her
journey is inspiring and as today John
went to therapy again and I go to
therapy so I definitely am a big
supporter in mental health what I like
about the way she did this one she still
made an entertaining video I appreciate
the sit down videos where you just sit
down and talk to the camera you don't
really put
cuts in it those are usually apology
videos but here you have to feel like a
vulnerable video yeah you keep it really
simple I like that and I really
appreciate that what she covered here is
some very serious topic some very raw
footage even featured footage from
something she took down I mean I've had
to do that but she still made a very
entertaining
Elva Mills style video while doing
something that's very vulnerable which I
really commend her for because this
could have just been a sit down video
explaining but she managed to do both
human Illustrated and really bring you
into her experience and in a way made it
a suit of vlog but with a lot more punch
a lot more impact you know yeah this is
a very start like she says at the end of
the video this doesn't have like a happy
wrap-up just sort of illustrating what a
journey this is especially when you're
dealing with your mental health and
especially if your dog down by things
like depression and anxiety to an
extreme degree yeah I thought this was
really effective and affecting and it's
interesting because I've seen a few
youtubers make videos of this variety in
different ways like one of my recent
favorite channels as Patrick aged
Williams and he even recently put out a
video basically saying that he's been
getting burnt out and the passion is
waning from the videos he's been making
and so he needed to take a break and
kind of restructure the output of his
channel and yeah it's a real thing and
it's funny because I think it's easy to
not maybe respect is the wrong word
let's go with the preview people on
YouTube I think there's a general
attitude from the outside that it's not
very hard anybody can do it and that's
true to a degree but once you're doing
it it is a lot more than you ever would
imagine you have to manage that you have
to juggle that you have to keep your
mind on it's so much more than just the
video yeah you know it's so much more
than just watching something and talking
or recording you're so yeah exactly
and now I do want to redirect all the
focus back to album mills in a second
like for us personally we have different
categories of how we do reaction videos
like if it's a giant trailer that we got
to get up right away yeah there's not
much editing that's put into it it's
more like okay let's make sure energy
said let's make sure we're focused let's
make sure our commentary sharp so we
don't have to
really edit is because we gotta get this
up right away that's just the fact of it
but if it's not one of those yeah we
don't really edit up the reaction part
we've kept that part wrong their
reaction channels were so much bigger
than us
absolutely who don't edit their videos
or provide much commentary afterwards
and we've decided to do that differently
so while most of our editing might not
go into the actual reaction like say
someone like I'm Dante I think does a
great job at how he edits the reaction
itself I love his style that takes a lot
of time just edit the reaction itself
our editing mainly comes in the intro
the outro and then you know of course
everyone's stuff like the movie reviews
take like an hour to to to edit for
lucky Lewton like the sketches take a
long time that's why we don't do them
very often because we're in this like
weird commentary area besides that even
though we have different categories for
all the kinds of videos that we do and
some are more editor than others to do
something that is required to be
entertainment mm-hmm it's difficult to
like we'll have like personal life
things and then to be a pro you can't
let that show sometimes and sometimes
it's going to and people are gonna send
you questions and messages being like
are you okay do you need some rest you
take a break yeah because I think from
the fact of how we are categorized as a
reaction channel rightfully so even
though I think we do a little bit more
for most rivers and other reaction
channels we often are told live right
super easy yeah there is that
misconception you see that's from just
our stance back to all the mills from
what she does mmm I can't imagine the
workload and the pressure that she has
to deal with like this is so much more
already and to be that young to yeah
what she is describing and here are not
exclusive to an influencer or to a
youtuber these are things that people
will generally feel no matter the age
you are doesn't have to be burnt out in
19 like you can be in your 40s or
something or our age and you'll still go
through these emotions you know well I
can't cite the source on this but I have
heard a couple times lately that just
this generation has become or is heading
toward being the the most burnt out
generation just overworked and over
hustled and the Western culture
especially in America less pay less
money yeah we got to work twice as much
society it's weird bizarre we work twice
as much but we make less than before
yeah and then every year you re up your
insurance for more money and less
coverage yeah we do twice as much now
because John and I are officially
partnered up but you know when I was
like doing this by myself it's a lot of
pressure you're reading everybody calm
and you're reading everything on social
media you're reading what everyone's
opinion about you of what you did or
what they want you to do and I can
imagine on her level it's a million
times more intense one thing I once
heard I think I Joe Rogan said is that
pressure is often an imbalance in
perception and of the day it's like it's
easier said than done just to be like
we'll just change your perspective on me
yeah telling somebody not to be cold
it's like there are things you can do
but it's not as simple as just stopping
yeah but I did appreciate this one I
didn't realize the amount of crazy
success she had and I think this is an
important video and I'd like to be 29
I'm watching this video I still I do
connect with it and I think we all can
admit to whether it's pressure and
success or pressure to achieve success
or whatever we're all under some kind of
pressure at some point anything
work-related
and you know creates it now do a part
out of 20 video silvered out alright
guys well thanks for being here thanks
to all the mills or someone in such a
great video and for giving us the
content you give you guys can subscribe
to the real rejects click the
notification belfie I haven't subscribed
at the already massively successful
hello the mills do as soon as you can
and Anisa thank you so much for being
you my dear you are a loyal patronage
act and beyond that you've just been a
great friend to us and you've been
someone who has been willing to be
vulnerable as well you're always honest
and you keep things light they're always
constantly supportive and I know you've
started up a channel recently just make
sure to keep the fun in mind you know a
lot of times people will ask me like
some youtuber vice and I'll just say
well at the beginning it's a playground
do whatever you want have fun do your
best not to lose sight of that don't
worry about being perfect just be
and because you is great enough as it is
so thank you for being you Anissa catch
you guys soon